shireen it's time for can't wait to see
week three edition you lead us off
well i think it's mike mccarthy being
second guess what's he gonna be second
guess for this week it's been two weeks
in a row his first two games with the
cowboys first week he bypasses a field
goal late that would have tied the game
and then last week they had the two fake
punts that didn't work and then the
two-point conversion that you and i
agree shouldn't have happened but it
happened anyway and he told a long story
yesterday and really tried to defend
himself and he called it convenient
criticism of his decisions cowboys fans
wanted jason garrett to be more
aggressive i think they want mike
mccarthy to be less aggressive but he
said he's not a gambler but he's going
to continue to take chances
i don't have a problem with taking
chances as long as they're calculated
and as long as they make sense
it makes sense because if you don't get
it you're behind by two possessions and
you give the other team an important
psychological edge and even if you could
make the argument that the analytics
requires it or at least if it's closer
it's 51.49 that's a result of doing it
over and over and over again football
coaches don't have the benefit the
luxury of doing it over and over again
when the goofy unconventional thing
blows up in their faces you only have so
many times you can get away with it
before you're gone i'm looking forward
to seeing josh allen trying to run over
aaron donald if he has that opportunity
he won't shy away from it but of all the
guys that josh allen has collided with
in his lifetime i think he'll realize
it's a little bit different when you
collide with aaron donald so for josh
allen's own safety i hope he avoids
aaron donald but if it's meant to be i
can't wait to see it happen
i also can't wait to see josh allen
against jaylen ramsey we remember
ramsay's critical comments of josh allen
and now the two face off again and i
think jalen ramsey's he was supposed to
talk to the media today but i'm guessing
that his opinion of josh allen has
changed since josh allen has actually
been a really good quarterback so far in
the nfl my second thing mike is i'm
looking forward to seeing jj watt and tj
watt going off against each other i
realize they both play defense and
they're not going to be on the field at
the same time but j.j watt will be on
the field with his other brother derek
it'll only be the second time in nfl
history that we've seen three brothers
on the field at the same time of course
the edmonds brothers did it last year
pittsburgh and buffalo so the watt
brothers would go at it i said the other
day that i don't think j.j watts one of
the top pass rushers in the nfl anymore
i people can argue that i don't think
you can argue that he's the second best
what pass rusher in the family
i i had a a vision there while you were
talking about tj and jj not being on the
field at the same time
of the steelers designing a package
where all three watts can be on the
field at the same time where tj comes in
as a blocking tight end get him in the
general vicinity of jj and let derrick
and tj go after jj that that
okay a guy can dream it's probably not
gonna happen but that would be awesome
if they find a way to get all three on
the field at the same time all right i'm
looking to tom brady saying farewell to
good uh or farewell for good to denver
and i'm sure he's looking forward
shireen to saying farewell for good to
denver he is eight and nine playing at
mile high stadium in his career this
will be his 18th and unless he ends up
playing for a different team or somehow
spends eight seasons total or eight more
seasons with the buccaneers he won't be
back in denver uh this is it and this is
his chance to get the 500 and the good
news is this is probably the worst
broncos team he's ever faced when he's
gone to denver so maybe he's likely to
get out of there at nine and nine but
for as great as he is it's amazing that
he has a sub 500 record at mile high
stadium
and i think it's the only team he has a
losing record against right i think
that's the only team that that he hasn't
doesn't have a winning record against
which tells you how great he's been i'm
looking forward to justin herbert a
second dose of justin herbert and we're
going to get to see him against the
panthers of course tyrod taylor is still
out but he just looks so good in his
first debut didn't know he was going to
play goes out and throws for 311 yards
against the defending super bowl
champions a touchdown ran for a
touchdown made that one rookie mistake
when he runs left throws back right but
he was really really good in his debut
and and i'm looking forward to seeing
how he does uh with a week of
preparation a week of snaps and of
course they have a little bit of film to
to look at that he played in since they
have no preseason film
yeah i i
i'm curious to see how he does this week
and whether he does so well the tie rod
tail or even when he's healthy won't be
back and it'll be the same thing that
happened to tyrod taylor a couple of
years ago when he was benched after an
injury for baker mayfield frankly justin
herbert far more spectacular and dynamic
than baker mayfield ever was as a rookie
based on what we saw in that first game
last one i'm looking forward to
will drew brees try to do too much now
that he is keenly aware of the criticism
we talked earlier in the week that even
though players and coaches say they
don't listen to the outside noise brees
was aware that people were talking about
yards per attempt and and and the air
yards and the other little criticisms of
his inability to get the ball down the
field will we see him come out and try
to uncork a deep ball and maybe under
throw
a deep ball and get it picked off by one
of the packers defensive backs it's
going to be a huge game on sunday night
with real playoff implications to the
extent that the saints and packers will
end up jockeying for position at the top
of the conference maybe a bye week maybe
a home game
maybe a better seed for the divisional
round so you don't have to go on the
road if you're the two seed versus the
three seed but i i i think that drew
brees was probably stung by some of the
reaction what happened on monday night
because he still had a solid game
statistically and and i want to see will
there be that conscious effort will he
seem like a guy who is determined to
shut up the people who may be raising
questions about what remaining shelf
life he has sharing
didn't he come out in that playoff game
if i remember correctly and he had a
long throw early in the game and it was
picked off he vastly under through the
ball and you said he just doesn't have
the arm strength anymore am i remember
remembering that correctly
you are that's the 2018 divisional round
game they had two weeks to get ready for
it this was the play this was the play
they picked for the first play from
scrimmage and he couldn't get the ball
deep enough kravon leblanc i think is
the one who picked off the pass and
that's what fueled the initial burst by
the eagles that put them in position to
potentially steal the game and they
almost did steal that game against the
new orleans saints in the 2018 post
season so uh
i look with
it's going to be fun to see what happens
on sunday night and and to really get a
feel for what's going on in that
organization because it's clear he can't
throw it deep and maybe it's going to be
clear that he's going to be determined
to try to do it all right